so as a stand-up comedian myself it is
an honor for me to have stand-ups come
and perform on this show and this next
performer is one of my absolute
favorites he's a very funny guy from
West Virginia who has his own half-hour
Comedy Central special he's also a dear
friend of mine let's go nuts for the
always hilarious Jared Logan everybody
jack
all right yeah uh hello I'm so happy to
be here with you guys uh I'm supposed to
tell you about myself so I'll tell you I
have a girlfriend she yeah she's real
and she and I don't have the same
interests sometimes yeah we don't have
the same like hobbies like okay I'm very
much you can tell by looking at me very
much into like you know like Star Trek
and x-men you can tell just by looking
at me right and she does not like that
stuff at all like even a little bit so
well but what we do is we compromise we
compromise when we are figuring out what
we're gonna do we compromise on what
we're gonna do that night like the other
day I said to her I was like look if you
go with me to my Lord of the Rings fan
fiction meetup group I'll go with you to
your ultrasound thing her thing was
boring and uh but there are things we do
like to do together
there are like we love to go to bed and
breakfast together like I'm like a
little small town like recently we went
to this beautiful little small town
called Saratoga Springs New York and you
know what these towns are like a little
cobbled Main Street a little ivy-covered
College and you know there's always
something fun there like a lesbian
holding an owl and you know what I mean
you guys know what I mean
so but sometimes they celebrate things
in these town towns and I think they
celebrate too much like there was this
sign up while we were there see what you
think of this there was this sign up in
this town reminding people to celebrate
take a child outside week
what's happening why why aren't the
children going outside what in God's
name happened like it sounds like
there's a kid tied to a radiator in a
basement come on Timmy it's for one week
a year we clean out your cage and put
down fresh straw you might get to see a
bird and the other problem is take a
child outside week that's a mouthful
there's too many syllables in that too
many words but you can't shorten that
you can't make it an acronym because
then you're saying to people hey are you
coming to Taco week are you coming to
the park for taco week oh no no no there
won't be any tacos now there will be
edit just children's squinting at the
Sun just pale children have you ever
gone somewhere do you think you're gonna
get tex-mex food and you get pale
children who need to be mentored there's
nothing more disappointing
there's nothing um I was a theater major
in college I don't don't clap for it
though because it's a weird thing to
major in I was on academic scholarship
so that's like you uh you get your
scholarship for grades right but then I
use that money to become a theater major
so that's like you win the lottery and
then you just spend it on beanie babies
soon anyway that's what I did and you
know then I had to I had to get a real
job you can't be Dame Judi Dench right
away which is my ultimate goal so I
would have to interview for these jobs
and I live in the south of the time and
in the South sometimes they don't really
know what feder is they think that
theatre is like a bunch of gay dudes in
a basement wearing makeup and making
their penises kiss which it can be and
there's nothing wrong with that
so I would have to go on these job
interviews and this is a true story one
time this guy's interviewing me and he
goes nah see feeder here on your resume
is that going to interfere with your
ability to work I was like no I'm very
responsible I'll be here every day at
9:00 a.m. ready to go and this guy
really said this he goes yeah but you're
an actor you could be lying to me and I
wouldn't even know I'm not a sociopath
when you defeated a redo get special
powers
this guy's like I can't hire you to work
here you can change your shape at will a
cup of coffee your the coffee pot get
out of my office metamour so I had to
take like a lot of temp jobs those jobs
stink they're no fun
you're always it's someone else's
cubicle with all their stuff you don't
like like one time I was in this woman's
cubicle she had a thousand post-it notes
and her cubicle it was like she was
trying to solve the Kennedy
assassination and her cubicle and all of
them had different messages and they
were all driving me crazy there were to
write on my field of vision the whole
time they were driving me nuts and the
first one said this gets weird but stick
with me the first one said three steps
to fix error two eight five and it said
one log in his admin to run detect and
repair sequence and three reinstall
Excel right beside that I swear to god
she had a post-it that said three ways
to be more happy and it said one be more
honest to free your heart from hatred
and three expect the unexpected that's a
good one but I think the danger there is
that you go to be more honest and then
you accidentally just reinstall Excel do
a man
over seven years you're like why am I
not happy I'm logged in as admin
everybody